Saint-Germain-en-Laye dans le noir en
solidarité pour l'Ukraine la ville
étendra ses lumières de Noël pendant une
heure sur les places et dans les rues
mercredi 21 décembre à 20h heure locale
l'action durera une heure c'est une
initiative du parlement ukrainien pour
soutenir le pays et elle concerne les
municipalités qui acceptent de
participer les habitants sont encouragés
à faire de même si vous habitez
Sartrouville peut-être que vous aurez la
chance d'apercevoir le Père Noël près de
chez vous avec sa barbe et son costume
rouge caractéristique Rémi foret un
agent éboueur chauffeur de la mairie de
Sartrouville a décidé de faire ses
tournées de collecte de déchets déguisés
en Père Noël il faudra cependant se
lever tôt pour l'apercevoir Rémi
commence à 6h il passe notamment par les
quartiers du vieux pays et de Tobrouk
apprendre à se prémunir contre les
escroqueries en ligne savoir les repérer
c'est ce que propose la ville de La
Verrière à ses habitants lors d'un temps
digital il faudra se rendre demain
mercredi 21 décembre de 14h à 16h à
l'espace Jacques nickel pour assister à
la conférence menée par un conseiller
numérique plus d'informations au numéro
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran si vous
êtes adepte d'escalade une nouvelle
salle a ouvert au centre commercial
Skywest à Montigny-le-Bretonneux à pic
contient 100 voix et 32 murs d'escalade
de 8 mètres de haut la salle est ouverte
à toute la famille des 4 ans plusieurs
niveaux de difficultés sont proposés
dont des murs de première grain pour les
débutants parcours d'accrobranche
toboggan ou bambou pour se jeter dans le
vide sont également présents sur place
comptez 15 euros de l'heure pour
l'entrée vous connaissiez Primark les
clés sous bois vous présente maintenant
Nomi son homologue français le magasin
ouvert ses portes à Alpha Park et
propose des articles à prix très
abordables installées sur 6500 m² vous
pourrez retrouver des vêtements pour
femmes hommes et enfants des accessoires
de mode et de la maroquinerie c'est le
deuxième magasin de cette enseigne sur
le territoire Yves Linois après
Aubergenville enfin dans le cadre du
plan de sobriété énergétique de 50 ans
en Yvelines la piscine Salvador Allende
située aux Clayes-sous-Bois et
contraintes de fermer pour les vacances
elle rouvrira le 2 janvier 2023